to Heaven at the left Point onetime COV go
coov he's going to ice this one up Tes with Roy
behind for ranin kicked it to his stick chipped
to the front McKinnon scores ranin bumps it out
McKinnon had to move it in a hurry behind in the
back right to marar step shoot scores kale Ma
has his first and it comes on the power play
physicality in front and ranted and all alone
in the mle and he dished it off for Taves and
the shot was deflected by fiala ranted and
[Applause] scores here's CRA Cuts back and
now it's headman with some room headman dishes up
they score Victor Hond sets it up to Steven stanos
headman flipped it across to COV two goals
for him in the opener on Tuesday headman R
shot scores Victor Hond with his third point of
the night a power play couple of big guys there
there's a long range shot knocked down by Demco
here's COV again COV dances shoots sto coach and
Demco came across and shut the angle down Paul
wins the puck battle steps out hangs on Co scores
second goal of the game and the ABS couldn't jump
on the rebound you're right Ray mckinon sniffing
for one here's a chance shot he scores right on
Ray Stan Co works it back up top to the point for
Hond near side for KRA in the middle back to krov
scores the reason because Victor Hedman missed the
game but total ice time against the big boys R
did a good job Point hangs on he's got K Dr in
front that's go and it's Alex bar Boule their last
power play lasted 16 seconds go CRA scores he's
done it again helmet down the car with his shot
that's why so stall had to go off GS replaced to
McKinnon with a dark move [Applause] St Nathan
M Kennon throws it right down to the crease well
and stall went to the bench nobody replaced him
look at McKinnon spinning on the wall watch the
back door right off the skate of Ryan Johansson
and that's a good goal all day long thinks it's
good I believe him because he's playing his
tail off it's husin lik it it to the slop SC
Nathan [Music] MN and the lightning have it one
minute to go in behind the net that's Paul CRA
quick shot tip scores and he's on the board bred
when it comes to overall momentum in this game
huge penalty kill for the ABS and then Bowen Byron
with his first Puck into the circle shot score
Nathan M the pitch and catch walks it out gives
it back to serach with a shot banned on it back
across and goes wait shoots scores Stevens stamp
go power play go quick Puck movement to marar as
he walks and looks and shoots added out of midair
by Johansson Anon will take over more than halfway
to go in this power play m to the dot St M ran it
and Shen knocked him away well that looked like
an interference penalty to me and Kennon gets it
back givs it off shot score B pum gets a perfect
feed from m get for point he chopped at that one
and then gets back after it onto his backand lets
it back for KRA they got the cycle going has in
the middle batted in by Victor head sta chops it
back to the line here's HCK with a shoty roller
that floated in on Johanson and he punched that
one down to a blocker now it's points point and
shoots scores Bren points gives the lightning
of the lead in the frame is COV off the faceoff
win tipped on the way through it's loose and they
score stanos flips it across to COV COV skates
away from Matthew Joseph onto the backand to
stanos stanos wrist shot scores Steven stanos with
a shot and was that tipped against chan chan took
a puck away from him so it's a two goal game
53 they score tipped in front as the lightning
answer right back here comes point back to the way
speaking of hot leaves it for KRA finds headman
open head shot scores Victor hman answers right
back Zev gets it away from Tyler bzi and he's
off Z Banks it up ahead stepping in over the line
here comes a pass scores Nikita coov one Tim on
the even stample flips it back to headman headman
COV one timer scores the coov puck was rolling
COV again steps in into the slot waiting shooting
scores Bren points continues this lightninging on
slot sideboard picked up by point point feeds it
to Hegel Hegel takes the puck wide goes across the
C scores what a shot by aita coov that that was
the chance across St goes cero what a save they
score the rebound what an initial stop but the
rebound found in six the devil's doing a great job
centering pass and lein it couldn't get it through
there's marar with a shot [Applause] SC ranted
quick transition ranted it with McKinnon ran
tries to get it through McKinnon St 53 avalance
now Kinski the 19-year-old flips it around the
boards to headman here's Jano again coer up
SC a little give and go of York stren now's
McKinnon flying in Nathan McKinnon gives it
a b shoots and scores B by top Shell by guow
and Philip guow knows that particular routine
he stopped it in practice an awful lot sent down
deep mckinon turns him back and scores they down
screen of about four guys here's
McKinnon wide open sends it up
top one time [Applause] SC Deon
from way down back it comes for
McKennon off the boards had to PMP it off
MC long shot there m r and gets one back
we just win this game two to one to the point
saes long R shot Sav to cour rebound off the s
and score M ranton and finally cleans up on the
doorstep you know my line is I always say I got
my mom's forarms that's why I couldn't shoot
here come the ABS cutting in McKinnon gives it
off through and shoots and scores Jonathan Dru
his first goal is a Colorado Avalanche out am
moiko four on three shot block gets it back does
r gotam McKinnon has creeping in back to mckin
finds K shoots score B toin right down in front
I believe got a piece so far on the night the
ABS oh for two on the power play here's McKinnon
finds kale long shot [Applause] SC kale M dials
it up from way out Taves down the boards finds 29
here's Nathan McKinnon Edge works so good now Mar
snaps it for T he shoots and scor the T he's on
it now he'll go back to the point there there's
COV point in the bumper Paul net front presence
headman lets it Go shot the score to center right
one minute remaining here in the first one
drops it off pass across the COV that one
directed scores theik CRA bang into the line to
McDavid and he couldn't turn and shoot following
up was bu that's knock by serff and here come
the liting CRA he's got Point CRA in scores
head here's Hedman Hedman hangs on kov back and
forth across tles [Applause] SC and the lightning
strike again on the power play it's tie game out
of the ice ABS have it M Wheels and looks steers
it off McKinnon back to Taves with the onetime
he scores Devon Taves an absolute rocket short
side mck straight up from a longer score B to heo
zutra what a finish here 7 Seconds stand across oh
they score they've tied the game Steven St Coast
with 4 seconds to go three opportunities to end
this game great pass I mean that's a beautiful
pass by CRA up to stamp Coast picks it up again
up top to headman near side for KRA St go with a
shot scor it's knock to head McKinnon he'll hover
in the near Corner wanted to Dish off comes free
Bron will shoot and he scores 107 to go in the B
Advantage with fetch nikov in the Box Here Comes
C trying to pick his way good draw back in the
middle for point is St go go St St go appreciate
how good this guy is and how few chances that he
really needs lightning do a good job of getting
the puck in the zone and they get all four black
18 seconds to go the man Advantage it's worked
down low out of the corner comes acoss scores a
onetime shot from the backside from the k coov
here's hman coov FL pass from point head scor
their third power play goal of this period
McKinnon to the back T Fresh Off the Bench
McKinnon one timer score valer NuSkin on the tip
gutov got it away to Hegel who Springs Point Bo
going to try to take off against Shake bra going
across to Hegel he shoot he's gone and now here
comes COV COV up the ice with Point coov scor
goodness what a goal but a COV and it's a five
point night and here he comes stepping into the
line with COV back for point point w shoots scores
so now it's points with a five-point game and
CRA is up to Six GS will peel away with it 40
seconds to go one shot on goal so far in this
power plays McKinnon gives it up dipped up top
here's Dr to the slot Sho scores jump the Dr
comes racing oh boy that was close that could
have been aing what a timely save by PR vov Here
Comes McKinnon serveing sends it down he scores
wasn't redirected gives it off for McKinnon who's
back in his space it's Gale looking down the slot
and he lost the handle Tampa getting a little
bit tired on the peak K long shot there St it was
deflected CRA to open ice for headman headman laun
stretch pass Celli he's in Celli scores Anthony
Celli pu is loose to McKinnon he'll race for it
Ean McKinnon gives it off for nukin Big B got it
on somebody throws it in the net and scor here
comes krov back over the boards trying to chip
that around give go COV to to the net across
scores coov to Braden he knows exactly where
Braden point is right here a little touch pass
there's there's where the play was made Sav by
jar who is extremely busy right now centering
pass again comes back to hman headman shot
scores CRA to Ser back to COV and he missed fired
in the one time puts it back to ser have second
have shot save rayen score on the stick of ran
it Val was right on the doorstep there's mckinon
one timer he scores Nathan M kenon goes top shelf
on the power but held in by Hond krov Victor Hond
there's the shot scores Victor headman in game
number 999 you want to put your stamp on the team
and you you want to stress to the young players
what winning hockey's about shot score Devon Daves
gets it in the near Ed it's McKinnon Top Line on
for Jerry Bednar McKinnon fing through a stick
to the near side Manson shoots score Josh Manson
Bren point this is certainly the dangerous line
for Tampa Bay they'll angle it cerab he turns and
scores trying to spy CRA in the corner they get
him and this one is left for chernak chernak
along the goal line out in front for Celli
SC Carlson's all over and makes the steal Leo
Carlson a centering pass but it's broken up by
McKinnon that could have gotten ugly in a hurry
but the ABS Counterattack McKinnon finds mcder
with a shot he scores ctis Tes floats one deep and
that's wide to the net love down by manson still
kept in Long wrist J sa gets it jum SC Nathan M it
back it comes to the near side Dr finds McKinnon
out of the trapezoid a back shot the a with it
the ability to move in 20 ft or more a couple of
times there and didn't take that shot from dead
center instead he gave it to C here's headman in
front TI score s power play goal Anthony for the
lightning comes back to Heaven here's Co up scores
a rocket from the top Point man in the NHL Nina
CRA two nothing rookie molinsky now takes right
to McKinnon he'll race in down de mckin back he
scores Nathan back Ken sends it out kib ronto
on the right wing is McKinnon try to get around
Dylan in the hip check McKinnon staying with it h
from SC no did it hit the cross far I thought
kimby Rona knocked it top shelf take a look
folks Nathan McKinnon Blows By the outside loses
the puck gets it over to KI Ron miles wood goes
in and here's the Moment of Truth yeah that's in
baby score Kenn walks by Manon right to the tape
of Nathan McKinnon down the left wing this time
we K it thorad s score Nathan man Kennon took
it all the way to the F and he was flying well
Nathan McKinnon is now scored or assisted right
into the top of the slot there just put it on a
tray for him now COV takes it up for Hegel here's
point kerov scor point to COV a chance for COV to
take off Seattle was changing they get their deep
back coo drove across to Celli Celli in scores
just what they needed now Hegel will wind it
up Hegel up the right side trying to skate away
from Everly Brandon Hegel across D score n COV
it's a lightning strike in over look at him Matty
benir just can't stay up with him and even though
he gots pressure from the outside side Everly
coming on him from the far the again set up and
that has not been a problem here's mckin dting
into the circle kale one timer he scores kale
thec an absolute ball kale swings it around for
R fired ahead b gets it up M on the Breakaway it
shoots and scores Nathan M Canon chance in the
air ABS take it away F off from mckinon and he
is flying down the way a little scissor move
gives it up m is in R it a try he scores he
got down step on that PO back to kale it goes top
unit set up here's raen looking cross eyes mckin
front score about stick check there by serach
and now COV trying to pull away Nikita COV up
the middle one-on-one with CC scores Nikita coov
what a goal great players come through look at
him fight through literally fight through to get
to this pu here's McKinnon again so far so good
on this power play but can he AB solving under
40 seconds left one timer wide of the net stop
score 53 saves in that game that's a career high
for a regular season game I'm going to say don't
ask he stole the game yeah there's a pass in
front it's score braen point the Calgary native
gets temp this power play on the road is overdue
Point swings and misses ends up with stanos head
shot scores Steven stanos bar it really is and
M wasn't just in that sweet spot he needs to
get in a sweet spot I agree with that too into the
slug [Applause] score B to chusen that might have
been a double deflection Shin bubbled it just a
little bit but he's so strong on that puck look
at him go t back to mckinon will he shoot this
time no gleed score m r but it's gloved down
by th couldn't get it out of the Zone here's
McKinnon down the slot he'll shoot off the PO
rebound it will go to m it's they Trail 5
to2 here with five minutes to go Jared bedar
did the same thing last night at Winnipeg
yeah credit to David Quinn too just letting
his team score Nathan back H it from the red
line disches to G COV hangs on takes the shot
St m co in over the line for Tampa Bay let the
puck all the way in Cuts back hangs on and the
just the COV COV [Applause] shot the COV within
second of the game great play from pert here's
McKinnon unable to collect that P gives it
back turn pass pass shot score b tuskin a
perfect little onetime from the low SL Waits
shoots and Patera got that with a stick and it
stick a flying out of his hands White Club gave
it back to him he's still scrambling they score
M coo ties the game works it back across to cra
cra carries that down low hangs on with looking
for offes AC cross goes off a SK de score into the
middle for points Point who is giv the lightning
the lead here tonight KRA out in front oh hits the
post that was Nick po Ray scores brighten points
[Applause] again and he'll get it back on the far
side you saw Corella make the push all the way
over to stop mckinon there's a shot SC f m Canon
sneaking inside the near spots that that puck can
find its way through S look hang on and SL shot SC
Nathan canon his second goal of period number one
himself all the way around foul fell down but kept
it alive finds Taves out mckin fake the onetime
free shot he scores na M kenon with a hatrick and
the a have tied the game in four down the boards
for thein wanted to give it back and does so the
as are now reset mckinon was calling for that puck
he'll find kale straight away back to mckin r
m r in the little rear after from the goal line
extended s bu with the left toe his left B and he
has clear it down here's McKinnon looking for his
for your D gra he shot score Nathan man K it's a
four goal night one of the best four Checkers in
the National hacky league right now 13k McKinnon
top of the circle gives it up for tames back to
McKinnon it goes across B one timer he scores B
to truskin hammers it from the dots bik takes the
buck Wi on get perfect set it back across the gr
then he gets it right back it back to now head for
a shot re sces Nikita COV the 300th goal of his
career ABS her close here's mckinon racing cross I
pass shot score M Ranon in down to one knee at the
bottom of the circle back it comes for kale finds
Mo again back to McKinnon take the one timer re
back to McKinnon one timer score flip pass back to
Heaven here St goes save rebound another one for
a point Pucket still lose St goes across shoots
scores kakenan must be giving the ABS nothing
to look at on that Far Side the ABS have shot
wide twice mckinn into the cross shot SC
Not that time the move got loose at the
bottom of the surf Anthony near side for
stanos stanos to CRA here's toan his shot
[Music] SC to COV COV up the ice in the
back hand leads it for hedmond hedmond
now stops up he's an in front they score hman a
beautiful pass to Nikita coach poked away still
a delayed call on the board Sammy G McKinnon
he'll Kick It Off Jeff Johnson gives it up
score B on the Sho up with headman Hedman at the
top to stamp Coos quick slap pass trying to find
Paul in front here's stamp Co again scor Steven
stamp Co with another Power Play goal in stride
to McKinnon and he is absolutely flying up the
ice ran it breaks her on gives it up Dr shoot
out SC Jonathan Dr settles it down and rifles
it inside the far final minute now of the third
period into the slot for p back to headman again
with a drive that went off a jet stick and C drop
scores Puck G right to him he slams it home fired
into the corner for moiko directed up top Mar
walking looking kale holds it shoots it's blocked
another one timer and the stick BS up and for
J bkin lot of ice off there no onetime
available kale inching M back to kale
the K one timer [Music] SC n m Kennon the
game-winning overtime power play goal for
his 20th of the season and the ABS have come
fir to head for wood and he'll work the right
wing this time tried to give it AC cross and the
Stick of McKinnon a back in score I'm not sure who
fou drops it back to the point mckinon can he
get one more off Far Side takes one timer save
W with rebound score it bounced into his five
hole and then a go Mount scramble COV again top
of the circles Waits needs it down low to Paul
back to COV up top to Hond headman with a shot
scores Victor headman with a rush tried to go
wide and he's cut off by Taves in a brilliant
defensive play Bang ahead and McKinnon's got
to break away to win it in overtime he scores
Nathan kenon wins it in overtime and
the comeback is complete have to see
something positive to go their way and get
humm here's mckin he'll find marar with a
shot hit the score kale Mar comes cruising in
it's a perfect feed he rips it past the all
the way around the board where it's corraled
by Carlo Carlo checked by Hegel little help
arise from keki there's a chance scores Bren
points of a forced turnover the Bruins give
no hard in the corner headman his dick breaks on
that hard play there's a chance scores Nik C who
else gets one Maran stick check there by headman
back the other way comes Hegel Hegel drops it out
to cro K nice move he's in back pass shot scores
what a goal Nikita K Dr brilliant puts it on a
te for brght absolutely brilliant Under Pressure
here's Hegel here's the speed then watch CRA that
between the feet the maintain possession and then
the back had P fir for Dr here's M K it down low
stop me go it down to one straight up top here
kale truway cross one Tim oh my gosh sa rebound
score B to chusi his second power play goal of
the game stanos Off the Bench walks it along the
blue line up top to perix calling for his dver
the middle point scor so radish radish back to
krov going to cut in CRA with the backand pulls
it back still with it gets it around us H shot
scores Darren radish with a lightning strike
in overtime couldn't get the puck away here's
krov in the corner up top headman and COV
across off the board stles head with a shot
score play the game it's time to take advantage
of you're the avalanche on this power play you're
missing B get another penalty coming up on the
leades already s down deep and fr A J score
Jonathan drwan it's a power play goal stanos
flips it back to headman KRA headman Victor
hedmond a good drop to point shot rebound s go
score [Applause] Steven zos with another Power
Play goal deep in the corner back up top to radish
here's C quick shot save do stall rebound pushed
back out to the line COV acoss to St goes into the
middle SC tip by braing points he couldn't triy
to fight his way he got out here's dreu drops it
for rent to McKinnon HS looks dle shoots and score
Nathan canon I think Jones may have
not expected this to come how it did
watch off the back foot he can't get a
ton of mustard on it Bron heals it off
for Gerard Sammy shoots and stuff like
it over the top oh Jake Allen did not
see that shot just missed a top Corner that
was in up top for kale one timer score kale
MC Rockets from way downtown for a two-on
one R it and finds McKinnon and that pumps
on the far side MCC cutting into the circle
shoots score M ran it in right on the doorstep
of the perfect leer they've had definitely
higher grade A scoring chances than the ab
had M too walks in and shoots the SCS
boo Ronin his second goal of the game
that they lost played last year for the
bolts as well that shot deflected wide so
Tampa down early headman again fires and
scores here's COV again he's skating well
tonight plenty of rest for these Tampa Bay
Lightning player shot oh what a save but a
goal did not have a power play
goal by wood but it acted like
one just as the penalty was expiring
push down deep save by Swan rebound
score on the far side McKinnon cleaning up on the
doorstep oh he had coer off but he made the drop
pass first and now coov ends up with it down low
Paul point in the bumper coov headman KRA F stamp
coach score I think it went off the Stick of Brock
F here's moo dancing into the slot redirected just
wide by drw back it comes to McKinnon sanheim is
out of the box bran it into one timer he scores
Meo ran in Tri to trying to Counterattack quickly
but the ABS recognized and this is one again givs
it up for McKinnon he'll burst out the slot shoot
it SCS Nathan M Kinnon Sammy G in the corner bumps
it off for KY R up top Manson walking in looking
cops it for McKinnon R shot stop Nathan ma m
Scoops that one from Mard almost lost his balance
shimmy move by Kale another re shot Sav by Aron
score it squeaks through the hole did ran it in
tap it in I'm not sure less than 30 to go hanged
off the glass out it comes a foot race McKinnon
is there with L McKinnon gives it up Logan o coner
shoots and scores it's an empty dead goon for loc
his first career hatrick the captain responsible
defensively breaks that up G Rob a point COV
again Hond back to COV he's in back to Hond
scores a great feed by cro clinical right now but
here's one last chance CRA with a shot block gets
his own rebound couldn't find it and now here's
a chance to the quarterback to COV scores Nikita
COV COV to stand Coast in the pass wasn't quite
the wheel he got through him got it down here's
Point Far Side COV scores his second of the game
a power play goal and his 30th goal of the Season
Edmond sets things up leaves it for Steven stamp
goes top of the circle to him and there's the shot
tick wide out in front scores Mikey aimon with
his second power play goal of the Season here is
Celli and again an empty net for aita COV and that
is a fourpoint game for aita C it's funnel up to
the point and Mar takes man back it comes for ran
cross eyes pass shot SC Nathan Ken it's a power
play go straight away kale looking for a shooting
Lan now Mo gives it back cross mckin one timer he
scores Nathan M does it again a power play goal
from the far circle on the one Tim in front
knocked Away by Gori here comes the streaking EO
he's got n with him ABS on the attack to mcken
M he scores Nathan M with a hatrick and the head
camera raining down in ball aren Le and McKinnon
took him wide Here Comes McKinnon again the ABS
are on side taned it drewan back to m boun p score
M it'll be five on four when comes out McKinnon in
front wanted to redirect oi is out now we're four
on four McKinnon high slot look shoots and scores
Nathan K with a mat trick his fourth goal of the
night second time this season with four goals
his fifth part of the night there's technique
to fighting but there's also survival bked
off the far boards for bra P he steps in score
Bren Point too much after the initial
play was cut off by Jersey here's Stan
go again Sten Stan go quick shot scores
it's co J again and they've got it back
pass across out in front for Point what Puck
mve they got going on this one here St goes
scar bym uses his legs to get that puck out
finally through it finds McKinnon high slot Nathan
McKinnon shoots SC you have got to be kidding me
I can't believe it what a shot for Nathan McKinnon
his 31st goal of the Season he's now had points
in 25 consecutive games since game one of the Year
here on the home isit ball Arena and the ABS have
a three nothing lead that was ridiculous convert
in fact never really got a couple more than a
couple looks at the net Mar R shot deflected
score I think Ross col may have gotten a piece of
it kale M Let it Fly and Van got a piece of that
out in front for Point tip just wide back out in
front perect shoots oh what a say R [Applause] SC
1 pass up picked off by coov coov to Celli again
dishes off and they score Brandon heel F Nets goal
53 this is all about kerov he is so smart